bonjour merci de m'accueillir
ici je vais essayer de vous parler un
tout petit peu d'intelligence
artificielle en lien avec le jeu j'avais
donné comme titre avant d'exposer libre
jeu avec l'intelligence artificielle on
pourrait le transformer un tout petit
peu autrement et plutôt que de lire
libre je moi je proposais de dire
éventuellement jouer sans entrave
donc si on peut dire pour penser à
terminator qu'il y aura un monde sans
humain il y aura surtout un monde avec
beaucoup de joueurs je crois plus que
plus que ça c'est ce que je vais essayer
de vous expliquer alors pour ça je vais
peut-être d'abord rappeler ce qu'est
l'intelligence un tiers serait bizarre
parce que l'intelligent étudiants se dit
c'est une activité extrêmement
rationnelle et donc il devrait y avoir
aucun jeu donc on va rappeler un
intelligent artificiel c'est d'abord une
discipline scientifique qui est né en
1956 donc c'est une vieille dame à la 60
ans vous me direz comparé aux
mathématiques ces très jeunes bien sûr
la physique mais ça a quand même un
certain âge donc disciplines
scientifiques qui a été inventé par deux
jeunes gens l'époque il avait 28 ans et
il le souhaitait étudier l'intelligence
avec ces objets nouveaux qu'étaient les
ordinateurs il a donné des résultats
tout à fait extraordinaire va revenir là
dessus mais l'intelligence artificielle
ça aussi un deuxième sens
c'est ce que lui qui est évoqué tout à
l'heure lorsqu'on a parlé terminator
c'est une entité qui serait mû par une
intelligence produite par une machine
alors là bien sûr on a un peu peur ce
qu'on se dit pas si elle devient
autonome si elle prend son essor tout
seul elle va nous supprimer en tout cas
dans ni dans le premier cas où on a
affaire à une science avec des
mathématiciens n'y a pas de jeu a priori
ni dans le deuxième il semble qu'il y
ait deux piliers de jeu
alors je vais quand même vous montrer
qu'il ya un lien avec le jeu pour s'en
va peut-être rappeler ce qu'est un jeu
alors un jeu ça peut avoir plusieurs
définitions
la première définition ces séquences
vous avez deux pièces mécaniques qui ne
ça colle pas tout à fait l'une avec
l'autre on dit qu'il ya un jeu c'est un
écart
donc c'est ça qui est très important
c'est le fait qu' il n'ya pas ajustage
complet alors le deuxième sens du jeu ce
qui vient de ce sens des cars hocus
cbteam au logis c'est une badinerie une
plaisanterie un écart justement la
raison instrumentale toujours cette idée
là et puis la troisième chose alors
c'est ce dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
plusieurs fois quand on parlait du poker
par exemple ou des échecs
c'est une activité ludique qui est régi
par des règles
alors est ce qu'il ya un lien entre
l'intelligence artificielle et toutes
ces définitions du jeu non il semble
qu'il ya un écart entre les taux qui est
un jeu justement entre l'intelligence
artificielle et le jeu je vais vous
montrer qu'à relativement peu de jeu au
contraire
alors pour ça on va voir pourquoi alors
la première raison c'est parce que en
intelligence artificielle
on a essayé de fabriquer des machines
qui joue
et on a obtenu des résultats
extraordinaires ans à prix très très
longtemps on a commencé par faire des
premières machines pour jouer aux échecs
alors le premier café ça c est la
lecture ig était même avant qu'on
invente le terme d'intelligence
artificielle mais ils s'imaginaient déjà
qu'une machine pouvait être intelligente
et comme les machines étaient très
lentes il a fait le programme à la main
et puis il a simulé à la main il triché
un peu mais ensuite donc il ya d'autres
personnes qui ont essayé de vraiment le
programme et ce jeu d'échec alors que je
crois qu'en 58 il ya eu un programme des
chèques qui a été fait et il a gagné sur
un être humain
alors en fait bon c'était non peut pas
dire que c'est est riche et bien sûr il
avait pris la secrétaire de l'équipe de
programmation qui avait appris les
règles du jeu d'échecs
une heure avant donc ce n'était pas trop
difficile mais ensuite donc on a
continué et l'un des pionniers de
l'intelligence artificielle à bertry
bonaldi dans dix ans les machines ne
sont pas exclues des grandes
compétitions internationales
elles sont championnes du monde huit ans
après on se rapprochait du terme des dix
ans un ordinateur a été battu par un
enfant de 10 ans on s'est dit ça va être
plus difficile qu'on imagine et puis
ensuite on a continué et un autre
spécialiste intelligence artificielle a
fait un pari qu'entre un grand maître
d'échecs il est dit en disant on va
gagner le guen le grand maître d'échecs
à continuer à gagner et puis on a
continué jusqu'en 1996 où vous en
souvenez peut-être beaucoup d'entre vous
n'étaient pas nés et jusqu'en 1996 on
fait encore que woods donc vous deviez
appeler mais tout petit donc 1996 donc à
ce moment là donc une machine a battu le
champion du monde en titre
gary dernier ce bar off et puis après on
a continué alors ce que j'ai ce qui est
important c'est de voir que voyez les
machines ont permis de jouer
il ya un écart on ne savait pas qu'elle
est laide de résultat et ça s'oppose à
une théorie mathématique des jeux alors
là il n'y a rien à voir dans la théorie
mathématique des jeux c'est une théorie
anciennes une théorie qui commence avec
l'espace pascal vous souvenez il fait et
puis ensuite ça continue bon il ya van
manen il ya plein d'autres gens il ya
cournot au 19e siècle et cette théorie
mathématique elle vise à réduire
l'aléatoire
d'ailleurs elle est utilisée par les
spécialistes de jeux de cartes etc
donc le but c'est d'éliminer le jeu mais
non en intelligence artificielle
on utilise quelquefois les résultats la
théorie du mais on cherche à faire des
machines qui joue et on arrive même à
faire des machines qui jouent mieux que
ce que prédit la théorie des jeux alors
c'est le cas d'un petit jeu cars et des
dizaines d étudiants et quelques années
alors ça s'appelle le baccara du bagne
vous connaissez le baccara de bagnes non
il ya un autre nom peut-être plus commun
pierre cizeau papier pas pourquoi ça
s'appelle le baccara d'yvan parce que
même quand vous êtes au ban que vous
allez trop jouer à condition d'avoir au
moins demain et une tête je pourrais
continuer à jouer et donc pierre cizeau
papier vous souvenez des règles du jeu
il faut jouer aléatoirement la pierre le
ciseau et le papier pour minimiser ses
pertes
et bien ce que faisait le programme
c'est que quand il jouait contre un
adversaire il essayé de regarder ce
qu'ils jouaient les régularités qu'il
présentait à son insu est ensuite hissé
non mais il n'est pas aléatoire
il anticipait sur ces régularités et au
bout de quelques temps ils le gagnent
est alors sur ce type 2 de choses fait
appel l'apprentissage machine on a
continué avec d'autres choses par
exemple avec le poker vous savez vous
avez vu qu'il ya peu de temps
il ya une machine qui l'a emporté sur de
très grands joueurs au poker et donc ça
veut dire que le jeu joue un rôle
important en intelligence thiel on a
testé tout un tas de technologies avec
le jeu on dit que le jeu c'est la
drosophile de l'intelligence
artificielle a peut-être pour ceux qui
ont fait un peu de biologie vous
souvenez ce que c'est la vie la
drosophile c'est cette petite mouche
qu'on utilise pour faire des expériences
eh bien on utilise les jeux pour tester
de nouvelles théories pour améliorer les
techniques d'intelligence artificielle
donc je n'ai pas seulement ludique le
jeu est aussi quelque chose de sérieux
mais c'est peut-être pas seulement
sérieux aussi le jeu peut être dangereux
et la question c'est est ce que nous ne
sommes pas des apprentis sorciers et ce
que nous ne jouons pas avec des choses
interdites d'une certaine façon
alors c'est une grande question une
question qui s'est posée depuis le début
de l'intelligence artificielle et qui
s'est reposé il ya deux trois ans avec
des grandes autorités comme stefano qui
ne vous souvenez vous des gens comme des
industriels comme elon musk que ne sait
tous elon musk 1 c'est lui qui a fait
paypal qui a fait ce pays sic à fêter
cela
même bill gates ils nous disent
attention avec l'intelligence
artificielle l'humanité court un risque
existentiel
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'elle court à sa perte alors est ce
que c'est vrai alors j'aurais pu vous
faire tout un exposé là dessus parce que
je viens de faire un ouvrage sur le
sujet mais bon c'était pas le problème
alors qu'est ce qu'il raconte c'est j'en
ai dit ce que les machines vont être de
plus en plus rapides comme elles seront
plus rapides les sons plus intelligente
que nous et quand elles seront plus
intelligente que nous elles vont prendre
le pouvoir
alors deux choses soit disparaîtront
soit nous allons nous greffer dans les
machines nous allons devenir des cyborgs
et nous allons devenir un menteur dans
tous les cas plus de jeu lorsque je vous
montrais c'est que tout ça ce sont des
histoires fausses je vais pas insister
là dessus
les arguments qui sont déployés par ces
prophètes de malheur ne tiennent pas la
route d'un point de vue scientifique
en revanche l'intelligence artificielle
j'ai parlé de jeu jeudi qu' elle nous
permettait de jouer mais il fait pas
seulement à l'intelligence artificielle
elle est aussi utile non pas seulement
pour jouer mais elle est conçue à partir
d'un jeu là tests d'intelligence
artificielle qui a été imaginé par
turing au début de la discipline
ça s'appelle le jeu de limitation c'est
à dire que c'est un homme qui limite une
femme là vous allez me dire y'a pas
grand chose il ya l'interrogateur il
pose des questions et en fait on
remplace l'homme qui met la femme par un
machine qui mitent l'homme qui mute la
femme
et ça c'est exactement ça lasse il ne
s'est pas donné une conscience à une
machine s'est pas créé terminator c'est
faire d eux des jeux d'une illusion
alors ça on appelle ça des haut rhin des
organismes informationnel alors qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un haut rhin en termes
de marine un haut rhin c'est le sait le
boot la corde qui relie une bouée et
lancre du fond mais c'est un peu la même
chose
1c haut rhin ces organismes
d'information l île nous relie au monde
numérique
et qu'est ce qu'on fait en intelligence
artificielle donc fait ce genre de
choses et toute l'industrie s'est
construite à partir de ça il ya eu des
résultats extraordinaires ces 60
dernières années ce sont des
opportunités formidables
il ya donc derrière l'intelligence
artificielle des aventures personnelles
des jeux justement qui vise à concevoir
ces haut rhin alors y'en a plein il y en
a une petite hache et pas si vous vous
souvenez de cette machine qui l'a
emporté sur le l'un des meilleurs
joueurs au go l'an dernier qui
s'appelait alpha go cette machine a été
fait par quelqu'un qui s'appelait demis
habits c'est un fils de 2,1 chez griotte
grecque et d'une mère qui était sino
singapouriennes
et il a monté une petite entreprise à
londres il rêvait de faire des machines
avec des réseaux de neurones
il a convaincu google google lui aide a
racheté son entreprise lui a donné de
l'argent et il est arrivé à fabriquer
cette machine extraordinaire
alors il y en a plein des aventures
comme ça moi j'ai un de mes étudiants il
s'appelait comme une femme et pas comme
ça il rêvait d'
de monter une entreprise qu'il a monté
une petite entreprise et un jour sa
secrétaire qui était portugais se disait
à monsieur gâtés ce qui vous a appelé
c'était bill gates il voulait lui
rappeler se racheter son entreprise
il n'a pas voulu il s'est dit non je
vais jouer il est allé aux états unis
j'allais le voir il avait une belle
maison avec une piscine donc c'est ça le
jeu alors qu'est ce que je peux vous
dire il ya un philosophe qui s'appelle
ludwig wittgenstein peut-être vous le
vous le connaissez il a essayé deux
logicien ses premières oeuvres c'est à
dire la vérité c'est une espèce de
tableaux logique du monde c'est à dire
qu'il a fondé la vérité sur cette note
aux notions de correspondance entre le
symbole et la réalité
et puis ensuite ce qu'il a fait c'est
qu'il a changé il a dit non la vérité
c'est un jeu de langage est capable de
répondre de façon pertinente dans un
contexte donné
eh bien je crois que l'intelligence
artificielle c'est exactement ça c'est
une forme de jeux de langage nouveau
dans le jeu actuel qui est celui du
monde numérique et c'est ça bien sûr que
nous sommes capables de faire avec
l'intelligence artificielle alors il
faut pas seulement être un technicien
mais il faut connaître l'ensemble des
possibilités offertes par l'intelligence
artificielle et ce dont je veux vous
convaincre ici c'est que justement j'ai
dit l'intelligence artificielle ça
permet de jouer oui ça permet de jouer
au sens en gros on fabrique des jeux ça
permet de jouer aussi où on peut jouer
dans le monde de la modernité on peut
jouer dans ce jeu de langage qui est
celui du monde numérique dans lequel on
se trouve et en particulier vous qui
êtes très jeune qui avait plein de
possibilités je crois que ça vaut le
coup de le comprendre on parle souvent
d'un séduisant actuelle en faisant ça va
nous prendre nos travaux notre travail
ça va nous prendre les activités il va y
avoir moins de travail pour le futur il
vivra du chômage je crois que celle
inverse
il ya énormément d'opportunités mais
pour ça il faut imaginer des coûts
nouveau dans ce monde qui advient
alors pour eux pour conclure je devrais
reprendre un vieil adage d'un moraliste
du xviie siècle en quelqu'un qui a l'air
un peu austère jean de la bruyère
oui il est un peu amer et dit tout est
dit depuis 7000 ans que l'homme existe
et qu'il pense
7000 en plus ni penser que la messe est
mignon c'est qu'il a beaucoup plus que
cette huile en tout est dit et moi je
voudrais dire non aujourd'hui rien n'est
dit et tout est encore à faire
depuis 20 ans que les ora existe et que
l'on croit qu'il pense et je crois que
c'est ça la leçon alors non dans le
double le monde futur visage et que j'ai
commencé mon exposé en dix ans donc
libre jeu avec l'intelligence
artificielle jouer sans entrave
je crois que pour jouer il faut
maîtriser ces techniques d'intelligence
artificielle pour les comprendre pour
être dans le monde contemporain
merci
[Applaudissements]